Welcome to EMAX as a Shell, a talk by Christopher Howard for EMAX Conference 2024.
In this talk I would like to explore or advocate for a particular perspective.
I want to encourage people to think of EMAX not as simply an editor or a development environment,
but rather as a shell, or at least something that allows us to do most of the things that
we might otherwise want to do for a shell.
What do I mean by "shell"?
By "shell" I mean basically an interface that allows us to interact with the rest of
our system by entering commands.
That definition is perhaps a little too broad, and so I will try to narrow it down with
a list of features that historically we have come to expect from a shell.
The "bash shell" is one very portable and well-known shell, and for many of us it is maybe
the prototypical example.
But in the past there have been many other shells, and there are other shells available today.
If we are willing to be flexible in our thinking, we can think of EMAX as being a shell, or
at least providing most of the functionality that we expect from a shell.
Before further expanding on this idea, I must emphasize what I do not mean.
First of all, I am not talking about running "bash" or some other external shell from within
EMAX, although this is certainly possible.
I am arguing rather for using EMAX as a shell instead of other shells.
Second, I do not mean running a terminal emulator from within EMAX.
EMAX has a built-in terminal emulator, but this is not what I mean.
A terminal emulator is essentially a program designed to control the cursor and text appearance
in response to various control codes, in order to mimic a terminal display device.
There are certainly legitimate reasons to do this.
Nevertheless, in general it does not make much sense to run a terminal emulator within
EMAX, because EMAX has its own commands for controlling the cursor and text appearance.
Also, due to the way EMAX was designed historically, EMAX itself believes that it is running on a
terminal, so you end up with layers upon layers of terminal emulation.
Anyhow, at the end of the day, EMAX will not perform as well as a dedicated terminal
emulator program.
I also think that, as we try to force ANSI terminal emulation into our EMAX workflow,
this ultimately will be a hindrance to us, in taking advantage of the natural and pleasant
interfaces that are already available to us within EMAX.
In brief, if your goal is simply to figure out how to be able to do all your normal,
bash, command line wizardry from within an EMAX window, instead of a gnome console window,
you were headed down a different set of train tracks than I am.
So something which I fear may confuse the issue for some viewers, is the fact that EMAX ships
with its own unique built-in shell, called the EMAX shell, or E-shell.
E-shell aims to be a legitimate shell, and provides a very similar experience to other
shells like bash, while being well integrated into the EMAX interface, and without giving
up the power of the EMAX-lisp engine.
E-shell will be mentioned multiple times in this talk.
The entire talk could, in fact, be about E-shell, except that I want to talk the talk to cover
all aspects of EMAX shell-like functionality through its other tools, such as interactive
commands and special modes.
So hopefully we can keep distinct in our mind the ideas of EMAX-as-a-shell, versus the EMAX-shell.
The latter is an important part of the former.
Let's get back to the fundamental idea of what is a shell.
In the broadest definition, a shell is an interface, which allows you to interact with your
operating system through commands.
However, from a historical perspective, there are a few basic capabilities which we expect
to be part of every shell.
First of all, the shell provides a means of launching external programs.
Some internal or built-in commands might also be made available.
And the shell provides a means of managing environment variables.
In the past, environment variables often played a critical role as a means of passing
in options, file names, device names, and such like two external programs.
This is not quite as common today, but the environment still plays a critical role in
managing things such as the path to executables and libraries, as well as various other user
desktop and system settings.
The shell modifies the environment and passes it on to external programs.
Historically, job control was expected to be either a function of the shell or easily accessible
from it.
Obviously today our personal computing is not batch-oriented, but typically shells can run
multiple processes simultaneously, as well as provides means to suspend and terminate
processes, which are useful features.
Shells should be able to redirect and pipeline process input and output.
This allows the user to connect process input and output with files, devices, or other processes.
Finally, shells are expected to have some limited scripting capability, such as the
POSIX compliant set of program statements and conditionals the BASH provides.
As command line wizards, there are a number of tasks we expect to be able to do quickly
and easily from our shell, even though these tasks are not the domain of the shell itself.
A common task is file management, a navigation.
We quickly navigate and manipulate the file system with standard utilities that do things
like change the current working directory, rename files, smooth files, and delete files.
We usually expect to have access to some additional process management utilities.
These allow us to do things such as find out the status of all processes running on the
system and send signals processes.
Finally, we expect to have access to some basic networking utilities.
For example, we should be able to run commands that set up network interfaces, ping computers,
and download files.
With a little reflection, we can see that EMAX can provide all or nearly all of the functionality
we have described so far.
And the functionality can be called conveniently through one of several methods.
Either, a normal interactive call, MX, something, or a call to an elist function, or through
eShell commands, or through some special buffer mode, such as the directory editor, which provides
its own interface to some functionality.
It may be going too far to say that EMAX is a full replacement for shells like Bash.
Nevertheless, we can see that EMAX can do most of the things that we might otherwise do
with our shell.
Let us give some examples.
First, can EMAX launch external commands?
Of course.
Now, there are something like a half dozen different ways to do that within EMAX and some are
more convenient than others.
From any elist program, we can call functions like make process and call process to launch
external processes.
These however generally are not convenient for quick one-off commands.
Another option would be to run eShell, which would allow us to call the external program from
a familiar command line prompt.
If we do not actually want to drop into eShell just to run one command, we also have the interactive
command eShell command, which would allow us to call the external program from a familiar
command line prompt.
If we do not actually want to drop into eShell just to run one command, we also have the interactive
command eShell command, which allows us to enter in a one-off command and run that immediately.
Finally, there is also an interactive command called simply shell command.
Shell command is like eShell command, but instead passes the command off to our system shell,
for example bash.
This is a cheating, of course, but it might be useful or convenient in some scenarios.
Starting environment variables, EMAX can read and manipulate the environment variables, which
in turn get passed on to processes which it launches.
The general purpose interactive commands for this are get environment and set environment.
These commands deal with the one environment that is available throughout all parts of your
running EMAX session, in other words, these functions deal with a global environment, which
is the same wherever you are running, get environment or set environment.
An important exception is that every instance of eShell maintains a distinct environment that
will not be affected by set environment calls run in other buffers.
Also, eShell has some additional syntax for dealing with its environment, including the
set and export syntax.
Starting job control and process management.
EMAX does not provide job control in the way that fast users are used to.
We can, however, launch asynchronous processes and do various things to them.
From eShell or an eShell command call, we can append the ampersand symbol to the command,
and this will cause the process to run asynchronously in a dedicated buffer.
Now if the command is launched from eShell, it will not actually run in a separate buffer,
but the output will go to the eShell buffer.
We can run the interactive command list processes to see all the processes running for our current
EMAX session.
In eShell, we can run the command jobs to get the same list.
This will show the process name, process buffer name, process ID and some other information.
We can select the process buffer in the process list to bring up that process buffer.
We can also use the interactive command signal process to send any signal to a process,
including stop to suspend the process, continue to resume the process and interrupt or kill
to terminate the process.
We can also use the interactive command, and we can also use the interactive command, and we can do it.
Regarding redirecting and pipelining input and output, eShell does support redirection similar
to bash, so you can overwrite and append files and some other objects.
Input redirection is not yet implemented, but it is on the eShell to do list.
eShell also has pipes.
The default pipe, which uses the familiar vertical bar symbol, pipes the data between
the commands using an intermediate EMAX buffer.
This, while usually quite practical, is less efficient than the system pipe.
Therefore, eShell also makes available a star modified version, which uses the system
pipe through a call to your system shell.
So we can do things like direct output to a file, where unfortunately not able to do input
redirection, but we can use pipes.
This can manipulate and tie together processes in various ways, such as process filters and
pipe processes, but I won't attempt to cover that.
I feel like you should mention again that we have two kinds of pipes here available.
So this pipe, the standard one, will pipe the data through EMAX buffers.
It's very practical in most cases, but it is less efficient than piping through the system
pipe, so eShell makes available another symbol for that star vertical bar that allows you
to explicitly use the system pipe.
Starting scripting.
Of course, using eMAX makes available all the power of the ELIST API and third party packages.
So we have that out of the gate.
eShell also has control flow statements, like an if construct and a for construct.
See the eShell info manual, section 3.7 for more details.
And if you wish to write a script entirely in eShell syntax, store it in a separate file.
This is possible with recent versions of eMAX.
Here is an example of a brief script that I wrote.
Unfortunately, in eShell mode for proper syntax highlighting is not yet available, but hopefully
that will be forthcoming.
Note that eShell syntax allows eLIST forms to be interspersed with regular command form.
For additional scripting power, we will discuss this a little more later.
Starting file system management.
In eMAX, many of the common file system operations are available as interactive commands.
For example, eMAX CD to change your buffer's current working directory and other eMAX commands
such as make directory, CH mod and delete file.
Of course, you can also drop into eShell or use MX eShell command to run the usual external
commands for file system manipulation.
Also a file manager is built into eMAX, which can be run by calling "MetaX" directory editor.
The directory editor is powerful, but it is a bit strange to folks expecting something
like midnight commander or the gnome file manager.
It gives us a number of helpful features like the ability to mark files and to run eLIST
functions on them and some other interesting ways to manipulate and rename the files.
However, third party eMAX extensions such as midnight commander mode and sunrise commander
are available to provide a midnight commander experience who prefer that sort of file management.
eMAX also has the nifty tramp functionality built in, which allows you most of the time to
easily edit files on other computers as well as manipulate the file system.
This transparently works through SSH and some other protocols that you can specify.
Starting networking features, I don't have a lot of interesting things to say about this
at the present, so I'll skip through this quickly.
But if you do a little research, you will see that eMAX has a lot of functionality relating
to making network connections, interacting with the web, and such like both built in and
available packages as well as modes for doing things like web browsing and Gemini browsing.
And of course, you can run the usual standard networking commands for your system through eShell.
So having put forward the main arguments for this talk, I would like to take some time
now to give a brief tour of a few of the features of eShell, the eMAX shell.
It bears emphasizing that eShell is not a drop-in replacement for bash, or even a bash
clone, though I believe the developers are trying to make much of the syntax very similar.
Also eShell is not a terminal emulator, and it will not display correctly applications
which used advanced ANSI control codes.
However, eShell can be configured to be aware of such applications and to run them automatically
within the eMAX terminal emulator when launched.
Csection 5.1 of the eShell manual titled "Visual Commands".
Though eShell is not bash, it has multiple features pertaining mainly to its spy design
eMAX integration which may make it more appealing to use than bash or another shell.
For one, eShell allows entering commands on the command line that are space and new lines
separated without parentheses.
Of course, all the other shells do this.
But within eShell, it is possible to enter internal eMAX functions, as well as external
commands.
eShell allows us to do things like this.
As far as I understand, it is possible to enter any eMAX function on the eShell command line.
However, some special syntax may be required if you are trying to pass in something that
is not a string or a number.
As you might have noticed in the last example, eShell makes it possible to use an eMAX buffer
as a sync for output.
It also allows using a buffer as a source of input, though this is slightly more complicated,
since the buffer must be converted to a string first.
I have distilled this down into my own function, named with the at symbol.
And I will provide the brief snippet of code for this later.
So to give an example, here is our Messengers messages buffer, and from eShell we can do something
like this.
Let's say here we wanted to graph our messages buffer to see everything that we had been
loading during the startup process.
So you can see how that could be very handy in a number of scenarios.
I wanted to briefly mention that we have a helpful function here called eShell insert
buffer name, which allows us to insert a buffer name into the current buffer at point
using completion, which can save you a lot of typing.
Another nice feature of eShell is that it allows integrating eLisp into the command line call.
Let's give another example, saying we wanted to echo the date to an event log.
I should probably take a moment to explain this asterisk that I am occasionally using.
So since eShell can use internal or external eMex commands, it may sometimes mess necessary
to clarify which one you want to use, since the names may overlap.
Since my eShell is configured by default to prefer the internal eMex functions, then sometimes
I have to use the asterisk to specify that I want the external version.
Here I can insert a bit of eLisp
and then redirect the output to the event log.
Last I want to mention that there are some optional eShell modules in eMex, not turned
on by default, which provide additional nifty features.
On my system I have most of the optional modules turned on.
An interesting module is eShellSmart, which does various things with cursor positioning
and scrolling, so as to make editing commands and reviewing output easier.
Let's say I was to change directory to my boot directory
and use a command which involves lots of output.
You'll notice right away that the cursor positioning is set such that I am immediately able
to view the top of the output, also I am able to use the spacebar to page through the output.
So this is an opinionated feature which assumes that you are likely going to want to review
the output immediately or that you often will.
Of course you can always jump to the end.
Also after a command is entered, the cursor is immediately repositioned to make it easy
to edit the command.
But also if I don't want to edit the command and I do not want to review the output, I can
simply start typing another command.
So that covers the brief tour of eShell features.
And that basically ends my talk, however a handful of viewers might be wondering is it possible
to set eMax to be my log and shell to completely replace bash in your log and experience.
The answer is yes, but in practice there are various difficulties involved which might
make it not worth the trouble.
Before doing this you'll have to answer a few initial questions.
Do you want to make a new eMax instance every time you log in or do you want it to connect
to an eMax server which is popular among eMax users to reuse the session or to connect
to the existing session?
Also do you want a different result, whether in graphical or a terminal environment?
And are you okay with your initialization file being run every time you log in, including
every new tab you open in a terminal emulator?
If we assume that you are using a system with Etsy password user management, you get one
field to specify the name of the shell program that you want to use and no arguments are allowed.
So maybe you can see how this might be challenging depending on your answers to the previous
questions.
You can work around these issues in various ways like modifying the authentication system
or by specifying a script for your log and shell.
But if your normal workflow is to simply log in and start eMax and run that eMax session
until your next reboot then it probably isn't worth the bother.
So thank you for listening to my talk, eMax as a shell by Christopher Howard for eMax
conference 2024.
At the bottom of this page you can see a link to the repository containing the brief amount
of code that was featured here in this video, as well as a link to my personal Gemini Gem
log, as well as a web portal version of that.
Thank you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]